it was unscheduled and unscripted the
press had to scramble to get these shots
just after 6:00 p.m. on May 29th 1988
President Ronald Reagan and First Lady
Nancy emerged from their limousine in
the historic Arbat section of Moscow
word that the American President had
come out to meet them unannounced
instantly spread and thousands of
Russians surged onto the streets despite
a growing worry things could spiral out
of control the 77 year old Reagan
actually climbed onto a vegetable cart
to address the crowd Reagan's press
secretary Marlin Fitzwater thought this
is either going to be a disaster or be
the greatest performance in history
hello I'm Bret Baier what that scene in
the Arbat turned out to be was the
dramatic opening act in a clash of
images words and ideas that signaled to
the world that the Cold War was all but
one I write about it in my new book
three days in Moscow Ronald Reagan and
the fall of the Soviet empire it's an
epic story with an unlikely hero or so
at one scene
[Music]
hard to believe but as a young man the
greatest of cold warriors was so
left-wing the FBI suspected he was a
communist in 1946
communists in the Screen Actors Guild
threatened to end Reagan's acting career
by pouring acid on his face repulsed by
such totalitarian tactics Reagan began
to take notice of communist expansion
overseas Russian ISM under the Kaiser we
met it more recently called Nazism under
Hitler
we're meeting it again now under the
name of communism and it is national
expansion in the part of Russia for the
next 40 years he was relentless how we
meet the Communist challenge depends on
you know critic of communism was more
forceful more uncompromising than Reagan
we cannot be by our security our freedom
from the threat of the bomb by
committing an immorality so great as
saying to a billion human beings now
enslaved behind the Iron Curtain give up
your dreams of freedom because to save
our own skins we're willing to make a
deal with your slave masters in the 70s
he opposed the Nixon Ford Kissinger
policy of date on my view of the policy
of de contas pursued by the
administration is one of making
concessions to the Soviet we give them
something they want very badly
we don't ask anything in return neither
the summits nor arms control treaties
stopped the spread of communism as
America looked to be slowly losing the
Cold War
after his loss to Gerald Ford in 1976
Reagan spoke movingly about the stakes
not simply the future of civilization
the survival of civilization someone
asked me to write a letter for a time
capsule that is going to be opened in
Los Angeles a hundred years from now I
thought to myself we live in a world in
which the great powers have aimed at
each other horrible missiles of
destruction that can in a matter of
minutes arrive in each other's country
and destroy those who would read this
letter a hundred years from now we'll
know whether those missiles were fired
they will know whether we met our
challenge Ford himself lost to Jimmy
Carter or the Soviets added satellite
states in Asia Africa and South America
when Reagan ran again in 1980 his
anti-communism seemed too many out of
step with the times but he won in a
landslide using his first press
conference as president to again
denounce communism mr. president what do
you see is the long-range intentions of
the Soviet Union
I know of no leader of the Soviet Union
that has not more than once repeated
their determination that their goal must
be the promotion of world revolution and
a one-world socialist or communist state
an assassination attempt intensified his
zeal not merely to fight the Cold War
but to win it
he and Pope John Paul the second who
also miraculously survived an assassin's
bullet just six weeks after Reagan
agreed that God spared them so they
could end communism and collapse the
Soviet Union the West won't contain
communism
it'll transcend communism when I came in
in 1982 Reagan was still in full
throated denunciation of the Soviet
Union he was still very much playing the
cold warrior what I'm describing now is
a plan and a hope for the long-term the
march of freedom and democracy which
will leave Marxism Leninism on the ash
heap of history few even among his
allies shared his belief that the Cold
War was winnable there was a huge
argument within the administration
people in the Defense Department in the
CIA both thought the Soviet rule was
there that Westar time we're here there
there that's life got a lot the American
public seemed to agree nearly
three-quarters favored a nuclear freeze
by the United States and Soviet Union I
urge you to beware the temptation of
pride the temptation of blithely
declaring yourselves above it all that
sparked Reagan's most forceful criticism
ever of the Soviet Union to ignore the
facts of history and the aggressive
impulses of an evil empire to simply
call the arms race a giant
misunderstanding and thereby remove
yourself from the struggle between right
and wrong and good and evil I was at the
speech where he talked about the evil
empire and the focus of evil in the
modern world it was stunning
even by Reagan standards that was pretty
blunt and pretty raw I remember just
asking myself and my staff saying you
know in a wooded Reagan have in mind
when he called them the evil in
which is really a pretty brazen
statement for a president to make about
another country and we just decided that
he really felt he could make things
better Ronald Reagan wanted to win the
Cold War from the beginning of his time
in office until the end he once called
him a principled pragmatist who's
strongest suit you said was knowing what
he believed and why he believed it he
had a system of going about things
number one be realistic number two be
strong not just military strength
economic strength but then more than
that have strength of purpose number
three figure out what it is that you
want then when we got all that straight
sit down and negotiate then you get a
hand to play but before Reagan was ready
to play that hand he dramatically up to
the ante
[Music]